these ideas of freedom and equality for
instance are not themselves self-evident
in their consequences or self-executing
they require us to figure out what do we
do with freedom what what is the meaning
of freedom right
um and it requires us to recognize at
the most basic level that America is an
argument we are meant to argue
perpetually we are meant to contest the
meaning of freedom we are meant to
contest perpetually the tension between
freedom and equality that when you have
too much Freedom you are trampling on
people's equality when you have too much
emphasis on leveling and equality you
end up trampling people's freedom and
that those tensions the tensions that we
go that go all the way back if you're a
fan of Hamilton the musical they go all
the way back to those rap battles
between Jefferson and Hamilton these are
arguments we are meant perpetually to
have and so what it means to be an
American is to be perpetually arguing
over what it means to be an American and
to be grappling with the contents of
this Creed it's not like oh here's the
Creed it has all the answers for us it's
here's the Creed it has all the
questions for us
[Music]
it's a pleasure and privilege to Welcome
to the podcast the founder and CEO of
Citizen University author of gosh what
is it six seven books including his
latest become America and someone I've
admired from afar for a long time Eric
Liu welcome Eric Andrew great to be with
you
you too holy cow man citizen University
I I like when a conversation starts that
way holy cow man yeah so for for people
who don't know why I'm I'm so blown away
uh how would you describe citizen
University to people well we're uh we're
a non-profit organization we're based in
Seattle but working all around the
United States and our work is really
trying to foster a culture of powerful
responsible citizenship and really kind
of change a baseline culture of how we
show up for each other and and in Civic
life
super powered citizens so how the heck
does someone arrive at doing this work
and I'd love to for you to retrace your
steps a little bit I mean you know I
have some things in common
um but uh you uh grew up Chinese
American in this country you went
through Marine Corps training as an
officer is that right
well when I was in college I did go
through Marine Corps officer candidate
school yeah yeah I mean so that that
that was an unusual thing I would I
would suggest uh and it seems like you
had a very deep sense of patriotism from
early on is that fair to say
yeah I mean I I would say you know the
in terms of background I am the child of
immigrants
um and I think uh you know as you know
well when you are uh child of immigrants
second generation American like that I
you know I grew up uh
um you know with this strong mainly
unspoken sense in the household
um you know my very chinese-american
household that
um all I had done was have what was was
to have the dumb luck to be born here
that my parents had done the heavy
lifting right and
um and so the question implicitly was
what was I going to do to make this
worth it
let's stop there for saying do you have
siblings I have a younger sister yeah
yeah
um so because my brother and I also have
a little bit of like though okay like
you know like why did our parents
sacrifice so much you guys had better do
something worthwhile yeah you know and I
think that that is uh there's something
great about that that's that can be a
lot of pressure you know but I think the
um the reality was that uh and I say
it's mainly unspoken it was just this
expectation
um but I think you know my parents were
born in mainland China went to Taiwan
during those years of war and civil war
came to the U.S in the late 1950s met
here
um you know New York and
um and so you know I grew up I grew up
in the Hudson Valley of New York which
you also know well outside of
Poughkeepsie and
um you know my dad later my mom too
worked for IBM I grew up in this idyllic
suburb at a time of peak American power
and prosperity
and that really does kind of you know
put a little oomph to the idea of what
have you done to earn this how are you
going to actually show up to actually
you know sustain this and you know I
wouldn't call that outright patriotism
per se but you know the other thing that
my my I have a grandfather who I never
met he actually died before I was born
but my father's father his name in
Chinese
um and you know Lou is a family name but
goyu and uh you know for our listeners
who don't speak Mandarin is it basically
means Deliverance of the nation right so
again no pressure uh but you know he he
was he was the son of a farmer in Hunan
Province he became a pilot uh during the
War years he ultimately became a leader
in the Nationalist Chinese Air Force and
uh uh you know fought the Japanese
fought the Communists all that stuff and
so I grew up with these stories of of
this grandfather and that shaped also my
sense of okay well how am I going to be
useful to this nation to my name to the
place where I've grown up that that's so
interesting you had like this uh this
military Heritage uh coming here though
believe it or not I was an IBM brat too
my dad worked for IBM uh not that far
from from your dad you were even
Poughkeepsie my dad was at Yorktown
Heights yeah yeah in 10 minutes we're
gonna find out we're cousins or
something you know seriously
um so you ended up getting into politics
also relatively early on I remember
reading about you in the 90s uh where
you were an official in the Clinton
Administration uh speechwriter domestic
policy advisor and you wrote A Memoir
around that time called accidental Asian
that came out in the 90s uh and uh as
someone who's Asian American I was like
wow like I think this guy is the most
prominent Asian-American Politico that
that I know of uh how did you get
involved in the Clinton administration
well first of all I love the circle of
life that uh I'm now getting to be like
wow I'm with the most prominent
Asian-American Politico right now and uh
you know I think it is uh
um that Journey you know I um you know
with the with the backdrop that I was
describing to you of just how my kind of
family culture was be useful be be
useful to yeah that's a pretty good
sound pretty useful
um you know that led me in college to
explore different kinds of of Public
Service I did internships in Capitol
Hill uh in the Senate
um as I mentioned I went and did Marine
Corps officer candidate school
um and finished that I ultimately chose
not to take the commission as a second
Lieutenant because I went after
graduation instead to go work in
politics and I worked
um on the hill for a few years and then
when President Clinton got elected
um I worked for him as a speechwriter
and along the way in doing that in
parallel I was just writing I started a
little magazine in DC at that time
called the next Progressive kind of a
Gen X that was back when Gen X was the
young whippersnapper generation I made
me remember that time
we were the ones who were you know being
looked down upon as the Young Generation
that was clueless and lost in adrift and
and I was like I don't like this
narrative you know I'm part of a
generation of a lot of young people
trying to figure it out and trying to
make our way together and so we created
this little magazine that work plus my
work in in government really shaped a
large sense of my you know of of both
the opportunity and the responsibility
that people like you and I have
um to use our voice you know we we both
grew up relatively speaking with a fair
amount of privilege
um and the question when you take stock
of that is am I going to hoard it or am
I going to circulate it
um and to me you know know getting
engaged in politics and public service
getting engaged in the world of ideas
was my way of circulating what I knew
what I'd gotten you know I went to Yale
undergraduate and and there too was very
steeped in an idea of be useful you know
don't don't just go go do this for your
own betterment and I think that all of
that kind of fed the spirit of of public
service so you you were in public
service throughout the Clinton years and
then they brought you back during the
Obama years uh
um in that time you also uh somewhere in
there you ended up collaborating with
Nick hanauer in a book uh Gardens of
democracy and while Nick who's been on
the podcast is trying to fix the economy
uh you've decided that we have to try
and Empower citizens and one of the the
themes of your of your last book and
there are a lot of themes uh when you
talk about how there's a lot of action
to be done locally that you you feel
like okay I spent years in National
politics and then I was the trustee of
the Seattle Public Library and I feel
like I learned as much or more as the
the trustee on the on the ground which
by the way is like I think a really
powerful theme so uh so how do you mean
I had a sense of what you meant when
when you said that but uh but what what
was it about the guts of local politics
that gave you a different perspective
well here again Andrew I mean you know I
think if we were to flip roles and I was
just interviewing you I mean the breadth
of
political experience that you've had
just in the last few years that that run
that same gamut from National politics
to you know though it's you know the
greatest city in the world New York is
still you know local politics there
um and I think you know for me
um I love my time in DC I was formed in
many ways and made many lasting
relationships there and friendships um
but there's no question for me that the
greater portion of my education in
democracy and in kind of small sea
citizenship and by the way when I talk
about citizenship citizen University my
organization where I'm not talking about
um documentation status and U.S
citizenship as a passport holding matter
I mean this kind of broader ethical
sense of being a member of the body
right a contributor to the community and
um and I think it's been living in
Seattle these last 22 23 years
um that's just given me this deep deep
grounding
um in what it means actually to try to
hold a community together and whether
that's being on the library board
whether it's you know Nick and I apart
from writing books together we we were
the catalytic co-founders of something
called The Alliance for gun
responsibility that we created right
coming out of Sandy Hook after that and
feeling helpless feeling as at that time
parents of young kids
um feeling frustrated that we knew
Congress would do nothing uh but feeling
that you know what this is a time to
awaken citizen power and to push at
least in our state here Washington uh
our legislature uh to act and if our
legislature wouldn't act you know our
state allows us to go straight to the
people and to put ideas and and
proposals for gun form straight to the
people which we did and all of those
experiences showing up where people live
dealing with the kind of hopes and
dreams and fears that people have for
their families in the texture of place
not doing the kind of talking points
abstractions Kabuki theater of national
politics
that's shaped so much more of my sense
of what it means to live like a citizen
and you know and just to go back a
little bit to what you're saying about
my my first book The Accidental Asian
and I've written throughout in all my
books whether they were explicitly about
race or not you know I write a lot about
race and American identity I I do think
um you know Asian Americans have a
vantage point that is that needs to be
heard and seen more in the discourse
that is literally and figuratively
neither black nor white and is about
trying to break these binaries that both
are racial dialogue and our political
dialogue often lapse into and I think
that that um you know that way of seeing
and thinking also shaped my sense of
um the way I want to move in the world
foreign
we all want to get a little bit more for
our money nowadays and one way to do
that is use expressvpn to access content
you can't get in the US let's say you're
a Netflix subscriber all it takes is one
tap of a button to change your locations
you can control which country Netflix
switches to I've used this when I wanted
to watch Vikings which is a great show
by the way because it wasn't available
in the US but it was in another country
there are now over 90 countries to
choose from and expressvpn works on
multiple streaming devices and services
not just Netflix so stop paying full
price for streaming services and only
getting access to a fraction of their
content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my link so you can get three extra
months of expressvpn free that's expr
ESS
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang Netflix and other
streaming services anywhere in the world
foreign
[Music]
so I was running for mayor in New York
City and then uh someone said we need a
mayor of color and then uh someone
responded Yang's of color
um and then the person said no of more
color
that was like uh you know I mean I
laughed when I heard it but it was it
was you know a reminder it's like that
Asians it's like well not white but not
what people think of when they
necessarily talk about people of color
and I remember when I was the last
presidential uh
candidate on the debate stage who wasn't
white um and and I joked with I you know
I was like the last candidate of color I
should say
it's really impossible to ignore because
they're only like six or seven of us
left it was just me and then they asked
me about it I remember enjoying that too
because it's like well I guess you know
we're gonna have to reckon with the fact
that uh Asians aren't white uh and uh
we're not really
uh included in a lot of the
conversations when people talk about
people of color
I'm glad that you and I have been
hopefully opening people's eyes to
different roles that Asian Americans can
take in this country politically and you
like full of credit to you I mean again
I've admired you from afar for a long
time like you were one of the
Trailblazers uh in this space and I feel
like now what you're doing with citizen
University is so fascinating that when I
first heard about your Civic Saturdays I
was like I have to look this up well
first explain to people what Civic
Saturdays are well thanks Andrew and
first of all I mean I I think those
those stories you're telling are stories
that speak to a lot of people right now
and I think the the ability to kind of
carve out a voice in a place
um that is about you know see me on my
terms uh but also don't put me in a box
and I think even the Box called Asian
American
um is a box that can oversimplify there
are a lot of people who are not Asian
American who think all Asian American
Americans are like you and me who went
to Ivy League schools and had parents
work for IBM and that obscures a huge
portion of the Asian American community
that has always been there that is there
um and and that is uh that has not had
opportunity that has been
um you know kind of stuck in privation
and discrimination and I think that
storyline also has to be complexified
but I think have you have you talked to
Jay Caspian Kang about this because he
he also thinks that the term Asian
American is in some ways uh not very apt
or or it's obscuring a lot yeah I I
don't know him but I I know his writing
and I think the you know the identity
itself look identity is always
racial identity in particular but
identity in general is always a
combination of of affirmative and
defensive right and a lot of
um what came to be known as Asian
American identity was born out of
Defense you know yeah if white people
were going to indiscriminately
discriminate against people and not care
whether you were Chinese Japanese
Vietnamese Filipino whatever and lump
you into a category and that at a
certain then at a certain point it
became the right thing to do to say let
us take this and turn it into a you know
make make a virtue out of necessity here
um and band together and make a
coalition across all these different
ethnicities and try to find Collective
voice so I think there is positive in
that and my that first book I wrote the
extent illusion was a little bit about
that ambivalent feeling that on the one
hand I get why this identity emerged and
on the other hand I don't want labels
that overly box people in or over overly
simplify or stereotypes about what even
contains what is even contained in that
box right even if we take for granted
the label Asian American we should be
able to see that the picture that one
conjures up when thinking about Asian
Americans shouldn't just be a picture of
you or of me definitely shouldn't be of
just you and me that's for sure
you know your question earlier about
Civic Saturdays this is um a big program
of ours at citizen University and Civic
Saturdays are Gatherings that we started
here in our home base of Seattle but
have since spread all around the country
and and we think of these basically as a
Civic analog to a faith Gathering
um it's not church or synagogue or
mosque but it on purpose has the ark and
the flow and the feel of a gathering
um in a place like that you know people
turn to strangers and introduce
themselves and talk about kind of
questions that cut past small talk we
have you know we sing together there are
readings of texts oh wait wait let's
stop there for just a second what songs
do you sing because when I think of sort
of Americana
you know but like I think the things
that pop into mind for me are like Bruce
Springsteen but I I doubt that's what
you all sing yeah well you know the idea
was to have songs that people together
can sing uh easily and and it runs the
gamut like here in Seattle
um you know the Civic Saturdays will
have Songs Like This Land Is Your Land
If I Had a Hammer a lot of the great
protest songs from the 30s civil rights
anthems
um and so forth
um but you know we've created a program
now called the Civic Seminary training
people to lead these gatherings all
around the country and so when they're
happening in other parts of the country
it runs the gamut people will sing
traditional patriotic songs America the
beautiful and you know the national
anthem others will sing songs that you
know are are more kind of you know less
less connected to the American tradition
per se but are evoking a different
Spirit of of community and belonging you
know and
um but beyond the singing there are
these readings of texts there are
there's a Civic sermon that someone will
give to help kind of help this community
make sense of the moment together and
then the most important part is people
then form up into Civic circles
afterwards to really talk about how are
we going to convert some of this
inspiration and Awakening that we're
getting in this Gathering here into ways
of connecting Anew or doing things
differently where we live in our town
right and in our community I I think
Civic Saturdays as soon as I read about
it I was like that is the most
fascinating
tremendous Endeavor because
I I think there's a real void in
American life for a lot of people uh you
don't have a sense of community
um it's a role that was typically filled
by organized religion back in the day
but at this point uh you know like there
are a lot of people who are not overtly
religious who would still want to have
some kind of communal Gathering and
there's something fundamental about
standing and singing songs and it got
through together this is very very human
and so I I thought adopting that format
was uh phenomenal and then that and then
I was very very interested in the
content that's why one reason I'm
interested in the songs I was joking to
a friend randomly about you know that
song and I'm proud to be an American but
so at least I know I'm free and what and
then that song I you know I always
enjoyed that song when that song
apparently has been appropriated as like
a trumpy song and I'm like oh no I can't
be a trumpy song
for many years and I'm not sure if this
is still the case that song was actually
played at naturalization ceremonies
that's what I'm talking about like you
know and and you talk about how
beautiful naturalization ceremonies are
and you you put in in your book The Oath
of naturalization uh which is beautiful
uh and I'm and you encourage everyone to
go just check out like what's going on
on these naturalization ceremonies
because there are people that are so
pumped
um to become citizens well I'll tell you
you know on that note alone you know my
wife Janae Kane who is the co-founder of
Citizen University she she has a theater
background and that's what it took well
like I think you say this too it's like
that it took you know having a wife with
a theater background well yeah but you
know I mean democracy and theater merged
around the same time in the same ways in
ancient Greece not by accident right I
mean both of these are about how you
actually create shared ritual of meaning
making and how you actually invite
people into experiences that actually
transcend everyday life and Elevate
their sense of you know being connected
to others being part of something
greater than yourself and
um and one of the things Janae and I had
been to a bunch of these naturalization
ceremonies over the years and I'd spoken
at a couple and you know they are
unfailingly moving right I don't
remember my parents I don't think I went
to theirs they just came back with the
little flags and little booklets and
stuff when they got naturalized but when
you go to this and you see you know
there's that moment in a naturalization
ceremony
um called the roll call of countries
where they kind of ask all the
immigrants who are getting ready to be
naturalized
um to rise according to the their
country of origin and then everybody's
standing and then they're told the next
time you sit down you'll be American
um and you know that gives you response
right and anyway we'd been to a few of
these and Janae with her kind of theater
background and having been born raised
in Louisiana kind of so though she
herself was not
um Evangelical Christian she was always
around that
um those modes of being and there's one
day we came back and she just started
sketching on a whiteboard like what if
we created something like this a
ceremony an experience like this that
wasn't just for immigrants who've taken
the test and want to become United
States citizens but was for everybody
was for people like you and me who again
had the dumb luck to be born here but
have never actually been invited to
contemplate the content of our
citizenship what it means actually to
show up here and what if we could create
a ritual that would be for everybody and
she started drawing this revival tent
she's like it could be you know this
revival Spirit but instead of being born
again you'd be sworn again and uh that
was the Genesis of this project called
the sworn again America project where we
created a little ceremony a little oath
that is non-partisan that is centered
around service and being useful to our
country and it is usable whether you are
you know a Descent of the Mayflower
whether your family just got here
whether you are documented whether
you're not documented it is for all of
us to claim this country and to make our
commitment to each other in living here
and we've we've seeded this sworn again
ceremony sworn again America ceremony
all over the country I mean it's
happened in places you know during the
Obama years at the White House all the
way to public libraries military bases
college campuses classrooms
and again that's a small project of ours
but our mode is trying to come up with
these little these experiences whether
it's Civic Saturday or sworn again
America ceremony that take people out of
the normal flow of either scrolling on
social media or just doing their daily
thing and actually stop and recognize
the minor miracle that we are making a
mass multi-racial Democratic Republic
here and and to kind of recommit to how
hard that actually is right and that
that stuff is long before long Upstream
of Elections and policy
um and traditional politics it's about
the prior sense of commitment to what
are we doing here right what is this
thing that we're trying to do and um and
being able to kind of elevate that with
a certain level of Civic spirit
good
I have always been into my mattress what
do I mean when I was in my 20s logically
I thought you know if I'm going to spend
eight hours a day ideally sleeping I
should like the mattress I sleep on it's
probably gonna pay for itself over time
in terms of health and energy benefits
Technologies come a long long way since
my 20s and now you can use Helix sleep
to get a mattress that's personalized to
you just take their sleep quiz at Helix
sleep.com they will send you one of
their 14 individual types of mattresses
to your home and you can test it out up
to 100 days risk-free how are they so
confident that you're gonna love their
mattress maybe it's because it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ wired
and my kids you know what I mean they
just seek out the mattress of the house
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com Yang
with Helix better sleep starts now
foreign
yeah and you you write uh that what
unites America is a Creed it's not
anything else uh and I thought that was
fascinating and apt when I was growing
up I used to think that what unify us is
culture
um though uh you and I grew up at a time
when there was a bit more of an American
monoculture than there is now uh back in
the days when there were only three or
four TV networks and everyone went and
saw the same uh TV shows and movies uh
Etc how would you define this American
creed uh that that unites us yeah I mean
I think the the Creed is it contains
ideas that are totally familiar to
everybody ideas that are baked into our
founding and our foundational documents
uh ideas of Liberty
um equality Equal justice under law
ideas of government of by and for the
people these words that in many ways
have become sort of Oh eye rolly you
know it's much easier to be cynical
about these words or to be scared about
the ways in which people have hijacked
those words uh uh for malevolent ends
but part of what we've got to do as
Americans is to recognize the a the kind
of remarkable I would say actually
exceptional inheritance that these ideas
actually are and Our obligation to
sustain them and and to kind of sustain
a sense of meaning in them but B that
the way that we do that is not just to
say hey people gather around and you
need to believe a little bit more in
freedom justice and equality
the way to do it actually is to
recognize that these ideas from the
get-go were ideas that weren't I mean we
talk about you know truth being
self-evident in the Declaration of
Independence but these ideas of freedom
and equality for instance are not
themselves self-evident in their
consequences or self-executing they
require us to figure out what do we do
with freedom you know there is a group
right now as we speak that's holding the
house hostage called the freedom caucus
right what is the meaning of freedom
right
um and it requires us to recognize at
the most basic level that America is an
argument we are meant to argue
perpetually we are meant to contest the
meaning of freedom we are meant to
contest perpetually the tension between
freedom and equality that when you have
too much Freedom you are trampling on
people's equality when you have too much
emphasis on leveling and equality you
end up trampling people's freedom and
that those tensions the tensions that we
go that go all the way back if you're a
fan of Hamilton the musical they go all
the way back to those rap battles
between Jefferson and Hamilton about the
size and the role of government and
Central national government versus local
you know voice and control uh the the
fight between the pluribus part of our
national motto and the Unum part
diversity and unity these are arguments
we are meant perpetually to have and so
what it means to be an American is to be
perpetually arguing over what it means
to be an American and to be grappling
with the contents of this Creed it's not
like oh here's the Creed it has all the
answers for us it's here's the Creed it
has all the questions for us and our job
is to know enough about our history know
enough about how people before us have
argued the Creed know about the things
that people have fought for fought each
other for struggled for the ways in
which they have not given up and not
succumbed to Mere cynicism you know if
people if if black people in the United
States in the 1920s 30s and 40s had just
said you know what enough it's been 70
years of Jim Crow I'm giving up on the
idea of freedom I'm just rolling my eyes
at equality that's never coming right
then then you and I would not be here
right now having this conversation but
because at critical mass a people said
you know but I continue I insist on the
meaning of these ideas even though
they've been betrayed from the get-go
and betrayed over and over again and
even though I today Labor under a system
designed to betray those ideals I still
insist that they mean something and I'm
going to organize by five by ten by a
hundred by a thousand uh people to come
together and shift the Norms that shift
the culture that finally will shift the
law in that case around segregation
civil rights but I think all of that
means what you know the Creed is is an
invitation to us to Grapple with its
meaning and then to ask what are we
going to do with it what are we going to
do about it and that to me
um again like yes that will eventually
get you to politics elections running
for office like you dude serving in
government like I did but long before
you get to that kind of stuff it's about
really spending some time and thinking
about what Have We inherited here and
what do we owe to this system and to
each other uh to kind of gain some
some Mastery of what it means to Grapple
with the American creed uh that's that's
profound uh one of the things you you
write about is that uh now our arguments
seem like they're let's see if I can get
this quote from one of your sermons
your arguments in American politics
today are stupid in many ways uh they're
stuck in a decaying two-party
institutional framework I'd agree that
they failed to challenge foundational
assumptions about capitalism or
government they Center on symbolic
policy skirmishes instead of naming the
underlying change the focus excessively
on style and surface I read that passage
I was like preach
because I agree with you on on all those
counts
um so why does it seem like we're having
dumber and dumber less and less
substantive arguments and what can we do
to try and drag them into more
productive uh zones because right now it
does seem like it's just increasingly
just clash Clash inco here and it's like
and I don't even know what victory looks
like anymore because what because we're
not translating it into uh you know
effective policy
you know I
um
I think about our work at citizen
University
um Often by distinguishing between
culture and structure
um and you know you've already talked
about both culture and structure and I
want to get back to what you're doing
now with forward party and and other
such Endeavors
um on the culture side
um what has made our arguments more
stupid what has made our Civic and
political discourse so unsatisfying
um has a lot to do with the incentives
of
the communications mediums of our times
right
um so you don't think social media is
making us more productive there
is a part you know inclusively it
rewards heat it rewards The Sensational
rewards kind of
um you know Amanda Ripley uh the author
has a great term for this conflict
entrepreneurs
that is a great term you know uh people
who make a living and find their life's
purpose in finding wedges where they can
stir up fake debates and false choices
and false binaries
um that that then lead people to kind of
you know are you with us against us and
and kind of amplify their Echo Chambers
right that culture uh which uh is you
know it's long-standing it didn't get
invented with social media but social
media has now made it a deep deep
pathology
um you know that's one part of it but
the structure piece and this is where
what you're you know doing right now is
important uh it's also that we have a
structure that feeds false choices and
binaries right and that of course begins
with a two-party system but it also
begins with a system of you know
elections that are
um you know winner take all first past
the post
um and all the work that you're doing
now with Fair vote and others to you
know Advance ranked Choice voting
um as a way to actually
um again complexify the ways in which
the Republic
represents us right a republic is just
supposed to be a a recreation of our
complexity and right now our Republic
focused as it is in this false binary
um leaves so much out of the picture and
you know the struggles again is we're
speaking right now the struggles that
are happening on the house floor over
trying to you know get a house Speaker
elected are evidence of that right I
mean it's a fraction of a fraction of a
fraction right who themselves were
elected by fractions of fractions right
and so
um you know so that's a structural
matter and I think you know
um if groups like Fair vote um and uh
you know with your help uh can actually
make progress as they are in
jurisdictions around the United States
and getting people to get more
comfortable with the idea of a different
way of approaching voting in a different
way of selecting those who represent us
um that will be a structural reform that
can address this the stupidity of our
political culture right
um but I think um you know part of it at
the end of the day too
um because you know to people who are
listening to us right now like they're
like yeah I agree you know but what do I
do right yeah and I think you know and I
think I think from my vantage point at
citizen University what we tell folks is
the other driver of stupidity in our
politics is the way in which
all of it is mediated such that you have
no there are no consequences you can
torch and Flame somebody on social media
you never see them again you have no
inner you have no relationship or
continuing interaction with them but
when you are grounded in a web of
relationship and obligation
in place rooted in a community and
you're going to keep on seeing people
over and over again that doesn't mean
all of a sudden that consensus arises
and magically people will still have
sharp deep divides and disagreements but
you learn to deal with each other in a
different way you learn to actually
humanize each other and I think you
can't blame someone who's on the the
co-op board with you or something
if you kind of recognize as you spend
more time with them you recognize oh
that person who I so dislike politically
um on this board with me or who's in my
neighborhood I realize that there's
another facet to them that their
families go in the same going through
the same Health Challenge that my family
is going through that they had a mentor
or a teacher who is very much like my
mentor or teacher that they faced a
trauma in their young life that's
similar to one that I know about right
and when you humanize in that way you
get to again popping people back up from
two Dimensions to three dimensions right
now our political culture flattens
everybody to two Dimensions right and I
think we individually and then in groups
have to recommit to rehumanizing each
other it's a political culture of
dehumanization uh and and that that's
that that leads us in really dark
directions yeah and I think that is you
know that's as much a part of the
solution as ranked Choice voting
um or you know other there are all kinds
of you know I co-chaired this commission
um on the on ways to reform Democratic
citizenship in the United States and we
had a whole bunch of recommendations
like ranked Choice voting like
multi-member districts uh you know there
are all kinds of structural reforms that
you can get to campaign Finance reform
obviously would you know diversify by
far the number of people who feel like
they have a shot at getting heard in
political life
um but I you know when I said earlier I
think about culture and structure in my
view and in the work of Citizen
University we think that culture is
Upstream of structure that culture
precedes structure that culture defines
the of parameters and the room of
possibility for your fights around
policy in the structural realm and so if
you have a culture that is dehumanizing
binary polarized nihilistic no memory no
commitments then your room for
structural change is very limited right
your ability to actually Advance policy
is about as wide as what you see it
happening on House of Representatives
right now right but if you have a
culture in which people see themselves
mutualistically interdependent with one
another think about themselves as
stewards part of a chain of obligation
that preceded us and will extend beyond
us and recognizes in a grown-up way that
yeah we're going to have arguments in
the point of American life is to argue
Our World Views but then to continue to
play the game that this is not a if I
lose one round I'm quitting or I'm
burning the game down it is a game of
infinite repeat play right and that
difference between a finance we really
hope it's infinite again
you gotta act as if it's infinite and
that is
because if you once you start once a
critical mass of us start acting as if
it's finite as if you could actually
wipe the other party or the other team
or the other side off the face of the
Earth and just gain total power then you
get into a death spire
so how many Civic Center days have you
personally LED at this point oh I mean
personally
um
dozens I mean just uh uh you know and
they started here in Seattle but for
many years I was traveling around the
country and and doing these in different
places and that book that you showed
earlier become America collects Civic
sermons that I gave at the first 19 or
20 of those around the country but like
I said earlier
um the point you know that was fun but
it is super not scalable for me to run
around the country and and do that and
so that's why we created this Civic
Seminary program
um where we are training people
catalytic people who are not you know
capital L leaders and you know big names
in their towns or whatever they're just
folks who decide like many people who
have kind of gravitated to your
political Endeavors decide that they
want a new way of being they want a new
way of being invited into the Public
Square I mean they raise their hand and
we've been training we just trained our
18th cohort of these folks they come
from tiny small towns of 500 they come
from big cities and they are leading
Civic Saturdays everywhere there are
people watch watching this right now
that are are like ooh how do I sign up
for this like what is there a selection
process what did they do yeah well you
just go to our website Citizen
university.us and um you know we are
it's a rolling set of applications we
have cohorts every couple of months and
uh
um and it's a great you know it's a we
call it a Civic Saturday Fellowship
because it really is a fellowship you
get trained over a course of a week we
bring folks out to Seattle and train
them in both the nuts and bolts of
holding a gathering like this but also
the deeper kind of ideas and ethical
Frameworks that you and I have been
talking about here
um but then after that week we send
people back and we support them over the
next bunch of months as they try to get
this going in their communities and you
know during covid this all happened on
zoom and people were doing you know
virtual Civic Saturdays but now people
are getting back in person and and
that's just a thrilling thing to kind of
you know again the double appetite that
people have not only to be part of
something meaningful and Civic and and
get out of their isolation and
loneliness uh but just the slingshot
effect of having been in covet isolation
for assault for so long and to remember
what it's like to make meaning and make
joy and make sense of stuff with other
people in a room together where you can
see each other and feel each other and
read body language together like that is
a gift you know it's it's a it's a gift
and it's a little bit of a miracle when
it happens and that's uh that's what
we're trying to Foster holy cow you must
be a proud papa every Saturday
and now in hundreds of communities
around the country there's someone who's
standing in front of a group of people
and they're singing together and they're
reading from uh you know it could I mean
it could be a poem a work of literature
the U.S Constitution a presidential
speech like you know whatever it is
um do you feel that every Saturday now
you know I feel a great sense of
gratitude it's not so much proud papa
and more like I'm so grateful that
people have responded to this right and
that people have decided to do something
with this and you know by the way we
often say like our our mode in spreading
Civic Saturdays is we're not Starbucks
we're tedx like we're not trying to
create a uniform experience everywhere
on every corner and every town
um we're actually we've got a frame like
tedx does where you know you got a
wireframe of what a tedx event is and
how it relates to a Mothership Ted event
but then if you do a tedx you know in in
Garrison New York if you do a tedx in
Palo Alto if you do a tedx in
Brownsville Minnesota where tedx in
Tampa Florida you're going to do it your
way you're going to do it in ways that
respond to the culture the Norms the
music The Sounds the vibe the the the
the the the the tone of your place and
your people right and
um and that's what we're trying to do
yeah I was struck by how personal your
sermons were in become Amer America like
I imagined that that there might be more
of like uh hey someone else could
deliver uh this this sermon but no one
else could because it's literally it's
like like you unpack you know your
family's history or like you know uh
like a personal experience and so I I
found myself thinking it's like wow this
would be tough for someone else uh to to
duplicate unless they were very very
talented they don't have to duplicate it
they don't have to do the the beautiful
thing is and the point is that if you
Andrew were to do a Civic Saturday you
know you would do it the way you do it
you would not be doing it to sound like
Eric Luke I I would be tremendous at it
you'd kill him yeah I would kill that
Civic Saturday come join one of our gym
come join one of our cohorts but but you
know but the idea at the end of our
Civic Seminary week one of the things we
do is we have everybody in the cohort
actually craft and deliver a miniature
just a five minute oh yeah yeah
totally and and they do that and I'll
tell you what like every time it doesn't
it never fails these short five-minute
sermons given by people who are not as
practiced as you or I might be in public
speaking are not as steeped in American
history or literature as I might be
whatever they give they craft and they
deliver some of the most moving powerful
resonant timely necessary
um little Civic sermons that you could
imagine why because they're being
authentic and they're trying to tune
into the community that they're trying
to serve right and if you've got that
then then the rest is gravy and
um and and so I think you know one of
the things I imagine you've learned over
the course of you know going around the
country and I know you're you know your
campaign
in many ways was powered by the thing
that I criticized earlier social media
but the but the stickiness of it was
that you were connecting with people
right and when you went to places and
people could feel the actual they could
feel the enthusiasm and energy of you a
bodily kind of you know Vibe right
um and and they could kind of connect
that way and they could now you know now
with forward party like look I'm still a
Democrat I I want the Democratic party
to figure stuff out
um and ultimately be able to kind of
sustain a you know a durable working
majority for positive inclusive
governance you know for a good long time
right but I welcome the emergence of a
foreign party because you know things
like the forward party you know you're
gathering together a pretty interesting
mix of folks right some who were your
early Yang gang younger people who were
just disillusioned with all of politics
others who were homeless former
Republicans
um who are completely disenchanted with
the ways in which that party has gone
off the rails
um who but who want to place where they
can kind of espouse basic you know core
values of decency but uh you know not
get bound up with with some of the crazy
um and you've got other folks who are
just you know uh Asian Americans who are
inspired that they you know that a
person like you is leading and the more
that we can create spaces for people to
express their authentic sense of
political voice and I think more
importantly and this is the thing that
you you really I think demonstrated for
a lot of people to know your own mind
you know so much of our political
culture is about repeating talking
points that you're hearing from your
team from Fox News or MSNBC you know
from one party or another and to
actually know your own mind and ask
questions and to kind of be able to
challenge orthodoxies on your own side
um uh you know that's a habit and a norm
that every one of us has to recommit to
if we're ever going to get out of this
situation that we're in right now
um and so Endeavors like forward party
you know I hope will actually uh you
know uh encourage people to do that
for for seeing exactly what we're going
for uh here Eric I mean uh if we can
help modernize the structures and and
give people
um more choices through things like rank
Choice voting uh than I think that you'd
see massive changes uh and hopefully
everyone who's part of the forward party
wants those things one just wants
uh more voices to emerge in uh less
polarized uh system
um and you know like I I was obviously a
Democrat for a long time and I want the
same things for people and families and
communities as I ever have uh and you
know like at this point I just wish that
more people had the same Spirit you do
which is like to have the confidence to
say hey I like this uh but something
that's going to be good for the system
like I can be for too yeah look I again
as a Democrat and also as an American
one of the things I wish fondly for is a
functional Republican Party
uh you know I it's not good for a
society to be a Mono Party Society it's
not it's not good for a society to have
one party claim you know all the symbols
of you know patriotism or or American
identity
um and even if and that's certainly true
when Republicans are the ones who've
tried to grab patriotism in the flag
that's dangerous but it would be equally
true if you know Republicans gave up
that and it was only Democrats who could
actually speak about commit Fidelity of
the Constitution and commitment to an
inclusive idea of American
promise and and you know the thing that
I find intriguing about for a party
it'll be interesting to see how you all
evolve over time is
it's you know to to not want
polarization is not the same thing as to
not want argument
um you know I think argument is good
um we have a little project that we're
running with the Aspen Institute and
um Facing History in ourselves which is
a great non-profit and and the All-State
Corporation we've all combined to create
something called the better arguments
project on the idea that you know we
don't need we don't need fewer arguments
right now we just need less stupid ones
right
all right look at this I hit on this
theme of like having stupid arguments
not stupid arguments right and I think
you know uh when you have something like
the forward party which is trying to be
a third thing you you are initially a
magnet for a lot of people who are
disenchanted with the other two things
um but that itself you know doesn't
necessarily mean that there's a coherent
affirmative
thing at the heart of the Ford party and
I think you know as you guys are now
committing to things like ranked Choice
voting and these kinds of democracy
reforms that to me feels like a big part
of the answer for how you can actually
not just be the land of Misfit Toys but
actually be the place where there's an
affirmative goal here and your goal as
the forward party is let's change the
way that rules are rigged here so that
we get out of false binaries and out of
stupid arguments and if all you did was
that you know Richard hofstadter the
historian said of third parties American
history that you know for the most part
they are like bees that Sting the Beast
of one of the two major parties and
force the Beast to move and change and
then die right and that may be the fate
of the forward party uh but if you sting
both beasts right now the Republican and
the Democratic beasts and get them to
embrace a different way of thinking
about rules and about the ways in which
we include uh you know people in the way
we think about primaries and and so on
and so forth
um that actually make democracy more
Democrat more small D Democratic
Democratic yeah then then a great
service yeah you understand it acutely
uh what's interesting Eric though is
that if we succeed in uh implementing
ranked Choice voting and nonpartisan
primaries like uh it would functionally
decrease the dominance of the two
parties which is one reason why uh I
knew that you had to go outside the
two-party system because like no
organization is going to say hey I want
to you know like have less clout I would
have less power
um knowing also full well that uh even
in a non-partisan uh ranked Choice
voting environment someone with an r or
a d next to their name still would have
a massive Advantage uh in in just about
every
District this has been a real pleasure
talking to someone who understands these
issues as deeply as as you do have been
working on them for
um for I I'm not to date you but I just
point I can safely say decades
I know a lot of people watching this
right now are listening to it are
thinking like oh I'd love to sign up for
civic Saturdays
um what how else can people keep up with
you uh benefit from your work support
you and your organization yeah well
thanks for that Andrew I think you know
I want to tell you about a couple other
projects that we have going at citizen
University that are ways that people
might also be able to to connect for
years we've been running this program
called the Civic collaboratory which is
a essentially a mutual Aid network of
Civic innovators drawn from across the
political Spectrum across all sectors of
Civic work silos of Civic work whether
it's immigrant rights veterans civic
education Civic Tech you name it and it
has included people that run the gamut
from tea party co-founders to Black
lives matter Advocates and activists
um and the through line is are people
innovating in Civic life to try to make
Civic life more include
and and more kind of to Foster bottom-up
power right and
um for years we did this as a national
thing and we call it a mutual Aid
Society because we had this format at
the heart of it called the rotating
credit club which is kind of like a uh I
mean it's it's like a lending Circle
where every time we meet four or five
members of the group will present to the
full group here's a project I'm working
on here's an Endeavor here's an
initiative or a new party I'm launching
or whatever it might be and the rest of
the group has to offer not critique or
commentary but actually hard commitments
of help and just kind of put into the
pot like I commit to help you with this
I commit to introducing it to this
funder I commit
um to you know strategizing with with I
commit to doing you know an alliance
with you you know on this project
whatever it might be and you might make
commitments with somebody you just met
at that meeting because the vibe and the
norm is what goes around comes around
it'll be your turn to be in rotation a
few meetings down the road and you want
that same kind of leaning in to happen
for you well we've been doing this
nationally for you know 10 12 years and
in the last couple of years we realized
actually this format probably could work
even better if it was rooted in place if
it was yeah you know in a local way and
so we piloted that in Chicago we've now
got to go in Atlanta
um and um one message I would have for
anybody who's watching is we are looking
for places all around the United States
right now that could seed a local
place-based collaboratory and we will
train folks you're going to get some
requests out of this for sure we will
train folks on how to how to run these
and how to how to organize them and then
send you back out
um to hold this kind of space right and
I think this is the again the bottom-up
spirit of this when you talked about how
you know in the work of the forward
party
the the two major parties are not
necessarily going to you know be excited
about things that might diminish uh the
power that they have you know in a
duopoly this is where you can actually
make a virtue of the of the unfortunate
fact that we have all been
geographically sorting so that many
communities are politically monolithic
and which is to say all all politics is
local but all reform of politics should
be local too right and so if you're in a
place like Seattle which is a deep blue
place you know where the only difference
here is are you a Democrat or are you a
socialist right then
to propose things like ranked Choice
voting is not about kind of helping
Republicans there are no uh Republicans
uh uh who who have the ability to get
elected in a community like Seattle so
now you're just among a circle of
progressive people how are you trying to
make the process
um of policy making in elections more
inclusive and more representative of
different people's issues right
um and that and the same would be true
you know um you know in in a red City
Missouri or wherever yeah yeah you know
and I think that that kind of but but
the local Civic collaboratory
um is another invitation that I want to
put to people you know and we've created
a youth collaboratory as well where high
school students around the country join
the National Civic laboratory every year
um you know both to get their own
mentorship and exposure to these you
know incredible people but also to
practice to do their own Civic power
projects to start figuring out how am I
going to make change in my community and
so if you're a high school student
somewhere in the country sign up for
that and join us for that well thank you
for the gifts Eric thank you for your
incredible work on behalf of really all
Americans uh and it's it's a joy to talk
to someone who's literally just trying
to supercharge citizenship in the way
that you have I enjoyed your latest book
become America Civic sermons on love
responsibility and democracy a great
deal and I hope we can find ways to work
together Andrew I really appreciate this
conversation and uh you know right back
at you I think you've
you've awakened and inspired a lot of
people to show up in new ways and I hope
you'll keep at that and uh and I look
forward to more conversation
yes Amen brother uh you can follow Eric
on Twitter too at Eric P Lou that's Liu
and uh check out citizen university.us
uh there's a lot of wisdom and power
there thanks Andrew
[Music]